pues la verdad es que ver a estos 11
astronautas que se están tomando
justamente en este momento la foto de
familia pues es muy emocionante aquí se
vio con mucha emoción con muchos
aplausos porque significa también pues
la una exitosa cooperación internacional
el resultado de este de este éxito de
ver a los astronautas que representan a
las cuatro agencias espaciales allí
juntos y en particular pues para los
tripulantes de crudos que acaban de
llegar a bordo de la cápsula dragón y
que fueron pues le dieron la bienvenida
desde tierra cada uno de digamos de los
jefes de las estaciones de las agencias
espaciales el primero en hacerlo fue
steve quien es el director de la nasa y
les decían además pues que esto
representaba también algo muy importante
en este momento en el mundo que se está
viviendo un momento tan difícil pues sé
que ellos eran esperas ahora después
pues de esto de esta foto de los 11
incluso de los 12 porque a bordo también
está win win que es el peluche un
pingüino de peluche que llevaron a cabo
cruz dragón esta es una tradición en el
espacio pues viene un tiempo muy
cronometrado todo el tiempo habita en la
tendrán digamos un briefing de seguridad
y ya se sabe que no va a ir a dormir y
luego será crudos 15 minutos después